when you start with the research and
work backwards to a logical conclusion
of how we should spend our time i think
focusing on things all day long is one
of the most disastrous things we can do
for our productivity
chris bailey welcome to the show
chris
yourself how are you i'm good tell me
about what you're drinking i am drinking
a lovely green tea i have cut out coffee
from my
repertoire and i feel
calm i feel focused it's the l-theanine
isn't it
i haven't had caffeine for 400 and
something 450 days or so now
how do you find it affects you
so
i wanted to see what would happen if i
cut it out at the start of 2021
yeah and i didn't really notice any
withdrawals none of the headaches a lot
of people talk about you getting
headaches and stuff yeah i was i would
say a moderate user so one coffee on a
morning
maybe a knocko which is about 120 migs
or 150 migs uh during the middle of the
day and then that would be it so what's
that probably about 200 throughout the
day-ish something like that so i'd say
that's probably absolute amount yeah
like a moderate amount um
stopped no headaches no withdrawals um
did notice that i had a craving for it
but my energy levels didn't really seem
to change all that much now
over the last year and a half i've been
stealth caffeine
a couple of times
you you think that you're getting
decaf diet coke on the gun
in post-mix that doesn't have caffeine
and it's come from a bottle that does
have caffeine and you get whatever 20
milligrams of caffeine so i've been i've
been stealth caffeine but like
purposeful caffeination hasn't happened
sleeps better
energy levels are more consistent yeah
um but performance in the gym is a
little bit difficult to get to yeah and
the high
that you get if you have a nice coffee
you know halfway through the morning and
you put some good tunes on for the best
yeah that's that's something that i miss
the most i think i'm going to take it to
500 days do a little report about an
experiment like this is i quit caffeine
for 500 days this is what i found was
good this is what i thought was bad yeah
here's some results or whatever um but
you are a
green tea fiend i heard you talking
about the fact that you shouldn't do it
at 100 degrees celsius as well oh
yes absolutely not that that is
sacrilegious to green tea people think
they don't like green tea people think
green tea tastes burnt and sour because
they order it at a restaurant first of
all half the people who who serve at a
restaurant they don't even know green
tea has caffeine in it speaking of
stealth
speaking of stealth caffeine there's
caffeine lurking in decaf coffee too you
know a starbucks decaf has like 40
milligrams of caffeine i think their
espresso has a ton as well but i love
the calming effect of uh of green tea it
has that l-theanine and so even if you
drink a coffee i really recommend
stacking that coffee with l-theanine um
the l-theanine pills which are you can
buy them anywhere pretty much and it
dampens the
adrenaline response to the caffeine
consumption because
caffeine increases or
coffee increases cortisol levels about
200 percent
and uh adrenaline levels about 200
percent but uh
that that l-theanine blunts the effects
of that and it's beautiful so you get
the the presence that caffeine can
cultivate with what you're doing you can
zero in on what you're doing in the
moment too
but you don't have that anxiety you
don't have that
that stress response uh there's even a
disorder called the caffeine induced
anxiety disorder or caffeine-ism uh and
so if you find yourself anxious after
consuming some coffee anxiety puts a
damper on productivity it puts a damper
on focus because it it narrows our
attentional capacity it shrinks how much
attention we have to give to whatever is
in front of us in the moment
and if you find that so it's kind of
this balance isn't it that the increased
narrow focus versus the
increased anxiety which can shrink how
how much attention we have to give to
whatever's in front of us in the moment
so that's why i love green tea i find it
gives the presence it gives the energy
but the l-theanine and it gives the calm
as well that that crushes that
caffeine-related stress response so
that's why i'm a big fan of it i i you
know i drink a cup of coffee every once
in a while for the buzz like you were
saying but besides that
i'm good i'm good with my green tea
would you say if someone's going through
a period of time whether ambiently
feeling anxious due to non-caffeinated
related things that avoiding coffee
during that time might be a good idea
specifically as well absolutely yeah 100
that's interesting i never thought about
that if you're feeling a little bit
anxious if you've got some stuff coming
up perhaps consider pivoting your source
of caffeine to something that isn't
coffee and and mind your energy too you
know if you if you find that your energy
is low at one or two in the afternoon
that might be because you have too much
caffeine
it might be because
you perceive more of the stimuli in your
environment as a sort of stress response
which just heightens anxiety it narrows
focus
and it provides us with less of a mental
capacity to deal with whatever's in
front of us in the moment this is
something that i that i found personally
and and you know i i used to give the
advice that we should consume caffeine
strategically uh when we actually
benefit from the energy boost
i still do buy that advice because i
think caffeine when it's well deployed
can work wonders it does depend on
whether we're an introvert or an
extrovert
if you're an extrovert
you can handle you have the capacity to
handle that extra stimulation but if
you're more on the introverted side of
the spectrum you're more stimulated by
default from the environment surrounding
you and so if that's the case for you
you might not want to consume caffeine
before a big presentation
or a big meeting right these these
stressful events that can threaten to
push us over the edge of anxiety to
begin with you don't need to to drink a
cup of
fluid liquid
stress in addition uh to that uh stimuli
dude that's so interesting so people
people that are introverted
their internal state already is
sufficiently stimulating yeah that they
don't necessarily need to add on top and
if they're doing something which is
going to add external stimulation on top
don't further make that worse with
coffee well i did an episode with dr
david sinclair he was one of the first
uh people that came on the show that
really blew up in terms of the episode
and i flew out to harvard medical school
in boston to go see him and he needed to
push back by half an hour so i'd rocked
up i'd got my little badge that had my
name on that looked cool yeah and i
thought oh i've got half an hour so i'll
go to starbucks and i'll sit down and
usually in the uk i would order i think
to
venti americano black right okay the the
big one black yeah nothing in it exactly
except the sweetener didn't realize that
the caffeine in the us versus the uk
i think is is a good chunk more so i get
back to harvard medical school to go
into david's lab and i'm like i'm
levitating yeah now across the floor i'm
just vibrating into his office and i'm
coming you're percolating correct yeah
yeah i was at the same resonance
frequency as the only dogs could hear
and wow i uh i i was really really
struggling for the first
15-20 minutes of that episode i'm like
trying to sort of calm myself down
nothing to do with the fact that i was
talking to this interesting person
everything to do with the fact that i
just jacked myself with whatever 300
milligrams of caffeine
yeah oh it's remark and this is uh
you know i look at the science of
productivity for a living and this is i
think something that a lot of people
miss with productivity advice is it's
personal productivity right and because
of that we're all wired differently and
so the advice that works for you might
not work for me might not work for
whoever's listening to this right now
and so we really do have to take what
works for us and leave the rest and
adapt for
not only the constraints of our life but
also who we are
our biology our wiring you know there's
all these articles like oh the early
bird gets the worm
and oh we should wake up at 4 30 every
morning in order to be
whatever
you know top of i don't i don't even
know what people say
but when you look at the actual research
the actual research shows that there's
no difference in somebody's
socioeconomic standing based on what
time they wake up at
it's what we do with the hours of our
day and how deliberately we live and how
deliberately we work that makes the
biggest difference with regard to our
productivity and that kind of dovetails
off of the introvert slash extrovert
relationship with caffeine and that
stimulation from the environment by
default we really have to take the the
advice that works for us and leave the
rest so question you know question
everything that i say today
uh obviously but i don't do you think
your interviews have gotten better
when you've cut out caffeine uh that's a
good question
it's difficult for me to say because the
skill
curve uh in terms of skill acquisition
is so steep yeah that i and i don't
intend on going back to being as bad as
i was 18 months ago to then
redo it again it's like i used um i used
a lot of peptides i ruptured my achilles
about two years ago about 18 months ago
actually
ruptured my achilles and i used a bunch
of different peptides bpc157
tb500 a bunch of different things to try
and assist with my recovery and
what people want to know is what sort of
impact did it have and you go well i
recovered quite quickly but again i
don't plan on rupturing the other
achilles to not use peptides to be able
to give you
a test that did i can identify what the
what the effect was even though some say
symmetry is the definition of beauty
okay so yeah maybe i should do together
maybe you should thick fat achilles on
both sides a lovely scar on both both of
the back of my ankles yeah i am the one
size fits all thing i think is
interesting and useful i'm surprised
about the
wake time has no correlation with
socioeconomic status the main reason
being
that
people who wake up
close to the time that most other people
wake up
i would have presumed would have
afforded them more opportunities
socially you're going to align with the
timelines and the schedules of other
people
that basically would have increased
ambient serendipity as far as i could
see you know what i mean you're just
doing more things at the same time yeah
um
but that's not the case it is about
deliberateness
you know and and that deliberateness
should be informed by
the constraints of our environment so if
you do have meetings at 8am
and you wake up at 9am that that's not
going to be that helpful
obviously with regard to to your
schedule with regard to your routines
but i i think you know if there's one
central theme
with personal productivity advice is
that
it's not about doing more and more more
faster faster faster it really is about
that
deliberateness and that intentionality i
think if there's anything that lies
at the core of productivity you know and
i think this is also something that many
people get wrong with regard to this
face
you know first of all there is no five
this ten step trademarked all rights
reserved solution for becoming more
productive that some consultant is gonna
try to sell you on you know you do have
to take what works for you and leave the
rest but the things that i have seen
work uh in myself so i like to do a lot
of experimentation with myself using
kind of myself as a guinea pig because
if i don't try the advice
i'm giving
what's the point of giving the advice
because
you know very early on in writing about
this stuff i i would recall writing
about things that sounded like the right
thing to say
but then i tried it out and i realized
that often the truth was the opposite
like the wake up time and especially
when you look at research after that
point and so
you're exactly right you know we do have
to account for the constraints of our
day and there are those common
constraints if you're asleep when
everybody else is working it probably
won't benefit from the coordination
that
some projects need you know there's the
collaborative work that we do there's
the individualistic work that we do
finding out where we are in that
spectrum can inform a lot of the best
productivity strategies that work best
for us
and you know
speaking of distraction distraction is a
necessary byproduct of doing work that's
collaborative we need it in order to do
work that's collaborative because it
involves interfacing with other people
and that's always messy but it's that
deliberateness and that intentionality i
think that is
what we should be
for lack of a better frame that i can
think of extemporaneously that's what we
should be optimizing
not only our work but our lives around
you know if you have a deliberate life
you're going to act and live in
accordance with what you value that'll
create meaning of course because meaning
is when we manifest our most uh deep
values through
how we act and how we work and how we
live and how we speak with other people
but it's that deliberateness that lies
at the
core of productivity advice that that i
i honestly have fallen in love with over
the years because if we can do the
things that we set out to do
what more do we need
that's your definition of productivity
right accomplishing what we intend to do
yeah yeah so
give me
you've written uh two books both on
productivity you may have written more
uh the productivity project and
hyperfocus and you've spent a lot of
time doing personal experiments plus
research plus sciencey stuff around all
of this
if
deliberateness
and intentionality
are two of the key
principles yeah that underlie the the
core of the productivity approach that
you've found
what are the
frameworks or the supporting structures
that help people to bring as much
deliberateness and intentionality to
their productivity as they can yeah
that's that's an awesome question
it's it's interesting because i you know
i don't start with some system and work
backwards to to the advice but my
approach is usually to start with the
the science that i can find on this
stuff is that much science of
productivity well
that's the awkward part is you hear
people talking about oh there's
thousands of studies that show that this
type of music supports
productivity but first of all the way
they measure productivity is usually
more conducive to work that we did in a
factory than doing work with our minds
and that's a big challenge to overcome
in the research
because just because you produce
something more with your time doesn't
mean that you actually make a difference
with your time just because you answer
more emails just because you work longer
just because and you know to
have a proper experiment something needs
to be easily measured and knowledge work
is very difficult to measure
you can write a 200 word speech a 300
word speech the gettysburg address was
around that length that changes the
course of history or you can write a 300
like crappy blog post about a a sandwich
that you ate or a green cup of green tea
that you drank maybe that's a bit better
than this actually it depends what's in
the sandwich
in my opinion but
measuring productivity is is a really
awkward thing that nobody really does
right because how do you how do you
measure knowledge work when the work
that we produce with our our time our
attention our energy
differs and it's difficult to measure
the impact of that uh but what i like to
do that's why that's the benefit of the
personal experimentation you know it's
an n of one
i don't have these these teams that that
that i coordinate maybe i should uh but
it's i see everything through my own
lens and and then i use the experiments
as a launching off point to examine the
research surrounding a topic
and my my whole philosophy is there's a
lot of productivity advice out there uh
in my opinion there might even be too
much productivity advice out there um
and i try to be the the person that
separates out all the stuff that works
from the stuff that does not work and
it's messy because it's knowledge work
and just because i write one thousand
words one day and two thousand words the
next
those two thousand words could be
garbage compared to the one thousand
words that came the day before and so
it's definitely not in an exact science
and the research surrounding
productivity advice is not always good
uh but the best advice that i have found
uh falls into three different categories
and this is kind of the the curious
thing and i haven't you know i started
with this i guess
you know i've been bashing frameworks
and and i guess this is kind of a
a natural framework that that appears in
the research is that most of the advice
not all of it
but most of the advice that allows us to
actually move our work and our life
forward uh it falls into one of three
categories the the first category is
time
of course we've always had to manage our
time around the schedules of other
people
that goes back to the factory type work
where
it was the environment where there is a
direct connection between how long we
worked for and how much we accomplished
with our time if we made one widget an
hour
and we worked four hours we made four
widgets baby and if we worked eight we
made it you know there's a direct
relationship
so time is the first ingredient of
productivity we've always had to manage
our time around other people and it's
like you said if we work in a
collaborative environment we need to
account for that constraints in our
deliberateness
the second component i see in
productivity is attention
right it doesn't matter how
well you can schedule things if you
can't then focus
on what you have scheduled if you're
distracted if you're constantly
interrupted if you don't have
as much
mental capacity as you deserve in the
moment
that you give yourself through your
habits through your routines through
your rituals
to accomplish things to the best of your
ability and it's not just about
accomplishment obviously right that goes
back to that idea of of intentionality
right what do you want to get out of
your time and you know that definition
of productivity it works regardless of
the context you know it if you intend to
write 2 000 words and maybe chris like
record like three podcasts or i i don't
know what the makeup of your day looks
like and maybe do a couple of interviews
yourself maybe and then you do and you
do a bang-up job of everything i would
say you're perfectly productive
and the exact same thing is true if your
intention is to put your feet up on the
beach with a two pina coladas one for
each hand obviously and just listen to
an audio book and soak in the sun right
it productivity begins and ends with
intentionality and i think that's how we
should be
measuring
our productivity in the first place and
that's why it gets messy that's why it
gets messy with the research but time
attention
those are the first two components of
productivity and i believe the third is
energy
right energy is kind of the
the fuel
that we have to burn over the course of
the day that fuels our willpower that
fuels our stamina that fuels our
capacity to get things done
so if you burn out at one or two in the
afternoon because you over caffeinated
all week you're probably not going to
accomplish much of your intentions with
that day because you're not gonna have
the capacity with which to do so uh if
you have like
i don't know if you go like some indian
buffet over lunch as i did the other day
and have a couple of delicious tiger
beers and like way too many plates of
butter chicken and white rice which i do
not regret i mean let me just say i do
not regret it but i did not accomplish
much that that afternoon
so energy i think is the third component
that not it's not part of my i guess
it's part of the framework that i like
to share but that's a common
idea that that repeats through the
research that these three
ideas and where they overlap you know if
we can manage our time well our
attention well our energy well
right we have to develop habits and that
takes time
but if we can get to a place where we
optimize all three
then we are far more likely to
accomplish the things that we set out to
do time attention and energy
but we still have deliberateness
and intentionality yeah sitting
somewhere around that yeah
before we get into those three
how
what are the ways that you ensure that
your deliberateness and your
intentionality is supported on a daily
basis
what a what a beautiful question i i i
have a couple of different strategies
that i use and you know i really think
deliberateness is a skill
it's not something we're born with it's
something that we can get better at over
time
uh the first is i have an hourly chime
on my watch on my apple watch
that i've disabled all notifications
from because that would negate the
effect of the chime
but essentially just taps me on the
wrist every hour and i use that as an
opportunity to reflect on whether i'm
spending those ingredients intentionally
and so i think okay what am i doing
right now and
is what i am doing
something that i made the decision to do
in the first place because an awful lot
of our behavior
is not something that we choose to do
right even if it's defined by somebody
else
we kind of go through the motions and
there's this automaticity with
uh with a lot of our actions that i that
i think
is a sign that we have room
to grow in terms of how intentionally we
live
and so that is the first i think
when that goes off i just do a brief
very brief reflection uh am i distracted
right now what am i working on is it
important am i spending my time
intentionally right now it's become kind
of second nature um and
when i'm happy
with the proportion it's never a hundred
percent of the time and i don't think
you know maybe
not even a buddhist monk on a meditation
retreat will get to 100 percent there's
always an automaticity especially when
you consider that 40 to 45 of our daily
actions are comprised of habits um
things that we do with that automaticity
and there's automaticity has has a a
remarkable place in our lives because we
don't have to force ourselves to work
out every day we get that we get energy
back and then we have more energy for
other things so that's one of them
the second is just a simple intention
setting ritual that i do every day
where at the start of the day i think to
the end of the day and i ask
okay what three things will i want to
have accomplished by the time that this
day is done
and it's a simple rule it and i think
the best productivity advice should be
right it's almost
it's kind of like how when something is
designed really well you think oh that's
obvious and then everything is designed
like that like the iphone right every
phone looks like an iphone now because
they got it right and when you get
something right it's so obvious i think
behavior is is a lot like that too um
and productivity is like that too the
the best advice like
eat well
exercise meditate focus tame
distractions it's all very very obvious
and i would include this piece of advice
in that in that bunch uh at the start of
the day fast forward to the end of the
day to find three things that you want
to accomplish by the time that the day
is done
um what i what i love about this frame
is you think not about what you have to
get done but
what you want you think about what you
want to be different
in your life
by the time you have reached the end of
the day and in that way you make
progress you make progress every day and
you won't always accomplish the three
things nobody does there's emergencies
there's fires there's things that that
arise that we have to deal with
and this shouldn't be all that you do if
you only did three things all day every
day you probably wouldn't have a job
after much of a period of time
but that's the point right right it's
it's in defining what is
more important than everything else that
we recognize the truth about
productivity that
not all tasks are created equal
right like take writing or maybe
recording a podcast for it for an
example to use what we're doing right
now
versus watching netflix right if if our
intention is to make progress with our
work it's very obvious which one of
those leads us to make the most progress
there's this this asymmetry of
importance with regard to the things
that we have on our plate and
recognizing that asymmetry and using
that
knowledge to inform how we uh how we act
and what direction we act in
so you know my three things today i
don't have them if they're in an app but
uh but i'll recall them so number one is
to structure talk number two is to have
fun in a few interviews and number three
is to write a couple of blog articles
it's simple there's email to do on top
of all that uh but those are the three
core things that i will want to have
accomplished by the end of the day and i
i do three personal things most days as
well
because then you decide every day just
how balanced you wish to be and so
there's a lot of simple strategies like
that
where we can make a
pre-decision
with how we act
that can inform how our day
uh manifests and and
increases how much control we have over
our time over time so i i love the hour
hourly awareness chime as a simple
method of reflecting on intention i love
the rule of three as well and meditation
and just general awareness i find not
only helps productivity but also
obviously awareness and mindfulness
how do you ensure that the three things
that you have set out to be intentional
about during the day yeah are things
which are given priority throughout the
day
now i understand that the
hourly chime is to ensure that you're
supposed to do the thing that you're
supposed to be doing at the time but
that
thing that you're doing right then can
be
email it can be yeah
you know there's going to be a number of
other tasks and i think i i quite like
the idea of three things what would i
like to have done by the end of today to
have moved me toward my goals um
because it allows for the fact that the
sand that fills the cup of that day the
inevitable sort of small things they're
just going to accumulate like yeah you
don't need to say do my emails
to know that you're going to probably
respond to some emails you'll probably
do it yeah i'll go to the bathroom or
you know go to the gym or whatever like
you know those things are probably going
to happen anyway um how do you ensure
that you instantiate the things are you
time blocking
are you
prioritizing using an eisenhower matrix
what have you found as the most
effective way
yeah it's interesting yeah you mentioned
how how simple the rule is and that
that's one of the beautiful i'll get to
the to the other part but i just wrote a
little note because i think it's
important to
uh to mention in talking about this idea
that we think in threes by default you
know i mentioned earlier the the natural
limit of our mind uh it's called our
working memory capacity which i just
think of our as our attentional space
which is just what we focus on and bring
into our mind in each moment and we used
to think that we can hold seven or eight
pieces of information in our mind at one
time but the latest research shows that
we can hold around three
and there are so many examples of of
this that abound in modern culture uh we
have sayings like good things come in
threes and celebrities die in threes and
the third time's the charm and the good
the bad the ugly and blood sweat
like we grow up with stories like the
three little bears the three blind mice
the three little pigs the three
musketeers even across cultures
uh we group things together into threes
a story
a novel we divide into three parts the
beginning the middle and the end the
olympics
they passed a few months ago
we divide into three parts the or we
award three medals right gold silver and
bronze so we think in threes and that i
think speaks to the science of
productivity where
where
we need to accommodate the science with
the tactics that we use and it's a bit
of a
a long connection between these two
ideas but that's why i think people will
find it works pretty well
the way i do it is by putting these
things somewhere obvious that this this
uh was what i did at the very beginning
uh before this rule became just so
it ingrained in my day that it became
invisible uh and so that's why you know
i don't have them obviously in front of
me because i've learned to structure my
time around this over time
and we all get better at this too and
and at first you'll probably overshoot
your intentions then you'll undershoot
your intentions you know if you are a
writer for an example it's an easy
example when it relates to knowledge
work
and you say
that you want to write 500 words on a
given day and you end up writing a
thousand
the next day you might think oh
yesterday works so well today i'm going
to set an intention to write 2 000 words
and again you might write a thousand and
over time though you settle into this
understanding
of
your capacity for daily accomplishment
while accounting for
the constraints related to how much time
you have so if you have meetings all day
how much attention you have maybe you're
going through an anxious period because
you're over caffeinating and you can't
necessarily bring your full attention to
what you're doing and how much energy
you have
so accommodating whether you're going
through a more tired time whether you're
maybe a bit more stressed and exhausted
at a given time but having these
intentions somewhere very very obvious
that you see on a regular basis as you
as you get accustomed to a habit like
this
and again
personal productivity takes take what
works for you and leave the rest
you may find over time you internalize
them because your mind thinks and threes
but putting these things somewhere
obvious blocking off time for them this
is something that i also love that that
you mentioned
having these chunks of time
where you focus on just one
thing that you know is important right
if you want to cultivate presence with
what you're doing what a beautiful way
of cultivating presence
deciding that you're going to do
something at the beginning of the day
having the confidence to know how
important it is
as you go about your day in the moment
it's so easy to get wrapped up in that
thing because you have the confidence
of that pre-decision and so time
blocking works really well having them
somewhere obvious works as a nice uh
reminder and one other thing
if we're chatting about this ritual this
is this rule works so well and it's i i
know it's weird to get obsessed over
such a rule so simple but i think one of
the that's a where it's so powerful but
be another reason it's powerful is it
works across different time frames and
so i personally you know have tried this
out for different time frames but i've
found that the best ones on which it
works is every day every week and every
year
it's a big jump between the week and the
year so do try out you know quarters
accommodate the rhythms and the
constraints in your own work
but i find there's
there's
that's where the rubber meets the road
with productivity when our daily
intentions feed into the weekly
intentions which feed into the
overarching yearly intentions are you
suggesting here that each week and then
each year you make a decision what would
have had to have happened by the end of
next week in order for me to look back
on this week and consider it a success
and then the same at the year yeah i
mean i think you know
one of the things that everybody comes
back to is this any large accomplishment
is just a series of smaller
accomplishments made up by a series of
micro accomplishments made up by a
series of individual tasks yeah given
enough time you could walk to the moon
like walking to the moon it's just one
foot in front of the other it is just
one step then one step then one step and
most of the time when i find myself
losing my way with productivity it's
because i have a poorly defined next
step it's because i don't know how to
accomplish the next step or it's because
i'm waiting on something to facilitate
the next step that i actually don't have
yeah and this is one of the
um interesting changes that i've seen
pivoting from my previous business which
was running nightlife to doing the
podcast full time and what i'm seeing is
beforehand it was a lot more
collaborative work whereas now it's it's
pretty much all on me um so
my ability to procrastinate has become
uh narrowed and far more personally
accountable yes it's not as if it's gone
away but it certainly has got rid of one
of those brackets like i'm never really
waiting on
someone i have all of the things that i
need i have the book of the person i'm
speaking to i have their information or
i have the audio recording or whatever
you know i have all the things i need
you have that beautiful webcam or i'm
guessing slr for the video version
slr yes so you said earlier on um
something that you bring up in hyper
focus which is that
there is a trade-off our attention
between thinking about future goals and
our ability to focus and this is
something that i'd never really thought
about very much that focus is kind of an
antithesis of our ability to do big
picture thinking yeah could you explain
how that works also sorry
the other thing the main thing that i
want to get into people today
the takeaway from your book is that
focus
whilst being fantastic
isn't a panacea it's not a q roll it's
not the thing that you want all the time
and it's the first time i've ever heard
anybody really ever but certainly within
the productivity space actually say
more focus isn't the answer because when
you think about
um i'm gonna go and play ultimate
frisbee later on today when i think
about that
i think yeah this is my time away from
work however the the point is for me to
be fully focused on what i'm doing as
opposed to kind of more free-flowing
and and
present and
feeling grace and ease and joy and kind
of that scattered focus that you talk
about but
let's go through the the trade-off
between long-term thinking goals and
focus
yeah and
it's such a
wonderful question because i think
focusing on things
all day long is one of the most
disastrous things we can do for our
productivity
and and when you look at the re when you
start with the research and work
backwards to a logical conclusion of how
we should spend our time you know first
of all
we don't focus 100 percent of the time
by default our mind is wandering about
half of the time which is not good when
we don't want it to wander
because when we don't want it to wander
we're usually trying to zero in on
something that we intend to accomplish
but it is remarkable
the ways that a
wandering mind can support us and what
we want to accomplish um one one example
that i
love to use is the how traffic flows
down a highway and so if you look at how
traffic flows down a highway
what
moves traffic forward is not how fast
the cars are moving
what moves traffic forward what allows
it to move forward is how much space
exists between
the cars
and i think our work and our life are
the exact same way
there's this wonderful quote that i'm
sure most people have heard before from
j.r.r tolkien
where he has written that not all those
who wander are lost
and i think the exact same thing is true
with regard to our attention with regard
to our productivity when our here's a an
interesting idea and and i usually don't
find
statistics that motivating in and of
themselves
because
i think in stories just like everybody
else on the face of the planet but this
statistic tells an interesting story
where when our mind is wandering
we think about our goals 14 times as
often
as when we're focused on something
that's sampling research done by
jonathan smallwood and jonathan schooler
i believe the name of this study is
called back to the future autographical
planning i i don't remember the full
name but you could probably find it
through google using those keywords
we unearth ideas when our mind wanders
we rest
when our mind wanders but we also plan
when our mind wanders and a good example
of this that everybody
is probably familiar with is taking a
shower
if you're taking a shower your mind is
hardly ever in there just appreciating
the shower even though there's a lot to
appreciate
we turn inwards when our mind is uh is
in the shower we think about the future
we think about what we have to get done
later that day we think about our goals
we think about our plans we think about
the intentions that we set that year
that week that day
right while our mind recharges and i
think that's the key too uh there
there's actually been research that has
looked at different types of mind
wandering so when we're mind wandering
kind of just on the floor or something
like doing nothing uh versus when we're
mind wandering doing something that is
habitual you know that 40 45 percent of
the time
that we're doing something that is a
habit over the course of the day and
research shows that we come up with more
ideas
when we're doing something habitual
because our attention
ebbs and flows with that activity it
moves us along and there's a there's a
rhythm led to our attention kind of like
a heartbeat where sometimes we need to
intervene with something that we're
doing out of habit what would be an
example of each of those yeah driving is
a great example of that so maybe you're
driving down
the highway and hopefully there's space
between you and the other cars uh and
you're kind of doing it out of habit
you're my you have a bit of highway
hypnosis uh where you're kind of
immersed in the task and you're thinking
about that you need to pick up like a
cantaloupe on the way home or so but
then you had a d you hit a detour
when you hit that detour
your conscious mind has to intervene
with the habitual part of your mind
that's going through
that activity automatically and that
that conscious intervention makes that
activity have that rhythm that heartbeat
kind of rhythm
that anchors us into the moment what we
usually do
in a time like this is we just kind of
listen to a podcast we listen to an
audio book and there's nothing wrong
with that of course it can make
something more fun especially things
that we tend to procrastinate on you
know you mentioned procrastination uh
there are certain cues that that that
certain attributes that a task can have
that make us more likely to put it off
uh that's something whether something is
boring frustrating difficult ambiguous
unstructured lacking in personal meaning
and lacking in intrinsic rewards so the
process of doing it is not rewarding and
making something more fun
listening to a podcast doing chores
around the house if you have that
intention to make something more fun
because you've been putting them off
that cancels out a bunch of the triggers
that a task can have
but other times
we want our mind to wander
because
it not only makes us more productive
when we think about our intentions our
goals our plans are
there i use the word dreams
our mind wanders to the future quite a
bit too uh what researchers call this
our minds prospective bias is is this is
one of the most uh remarkable parts of
of zooming in on this idea uh of
attention in the uh
in the book that you mentioned i won't
mention the name of the book again
because i hate when people plug their
stuff constantly but when you look at
where our mind wanders to
our mind wanders to think about the
future 48 of the time so about half of
the time our mind is just kind of in the
shower we're driving we're doing the
dishes
we're planning right and 28 of the time
we're thinking about the present we're
this is when you're typing up an email
and you can't figure out how to phrase
it so you walk across uh your what do
you call it a flat a department uh and
uh on the way there when you're on your
way to make a cup of
green tea not coffee
the solution hits you and then you run
back you type up the email you figure
out how to phrase it and you forgot
about the green tea in the first place
uh we do want her to think about the
past around 12 percent of the time but a
lot of that time we're recalling ideas
sometimes we do recall you know those
cringe-worthy memories of stupid things
that you've said uh we do recall that
sometimes but
uh most of the time we're thinking about
ideas and where we connect all three
right where all three meet in the middle
it's great to plan it's great to rest
it's great to recharge doing something
habitual
but when we connect
the past to the present to the future to
the present the past of the future
and so on
we think about an idea that we heard on
a podcast and we connect that to a
problem that we're facing in that
present moment and we connect that to a
conversation we might have in the future
and then we think about that future
conversation
when we connect all three
mental
temporal destinations we arrive at ideas
that we would
never
have arrived at if we were just focused
on something if we were on twitter if we
were checking email one more time
there is
you know economists refer to it as
diminishing marginal utility where
our enjoyment of something goes down you
know that that
30th
bite of ice cream is way less novel than
the first and the first by god you might
be thrown up uh productivity is the same
way right that 30th check of email is
probably a lot less necessary than just
going for a walk you know it's mind
wandering that
makes that space between the things that
we do meaningful
so if that's the advantage of how to
unfocus
of how to relinquish our focus
throughout the day
talk to me about the science and the
strategies around when we need to put
the hammer down when we need to actually
get in we've got a thing that we need to
do yeah the proposal needs finishing the
podcast needs editing the article needs
writing whatever yeah
yeah there's
it's funny because
relative to the research on on that that
deliberate mind wandering uh which i
call scatter focus because deliberate
saying deliberate mind wandering every
time is is kind of awkward um
you know the relatively speaking the
steps to devoting our
full attention to something are quite
simple
and if you look at the rhythms that
our attention has throughout the day you
know the research shows something very
very obvious
in hindsight
and it's funny how much research is
sometimes conducted to prove something
so obvious you know we focus on
something
our mind gets distracted by something
internal or external
which is in sampling studies show that
we get
distracted internally versus externally
about the same proportion uh then we
notice that our mind has veered off then
we bring it back um it's simple right
this happens repeatedly as we ebb and
flow through
uh periods of intentional mind wandering
unintentional mind wandering and focus
um you know the mind wandering again
about half of the day focus the other
half so we can combine this with uh some
ideas from the science of intentionality
which i find to be interesting and
something i'm planning on doing a a
deeper dive into in the future too
we can choose
first of all
what we want to focus on
and ideally that's something that is
productive and so it produces uh
something that will lead us to make
progress that we want or something that
is meaningful
right an experience that we want to
to live
fully
right because that is that's what life
is right like what's the point if we're
not going to just
have this deep
presence with what we're doing if we're
just running from one moment to the next
so
the pre-decision for lack of a better
term that the choice um that's where
intentionality comes in uh then ideally
you know
here's the thing about obstacles as it
relates to anything goals in general
focus too
obstacles are infinitely
more difficult to deal with when they
come up compared to dealing with them
ahead of time
and so you mentioned working out a time
or two that's a good example of that we
all have fitness routines or fitness
ambitions
and the truth is if you have a period of
travel coming up
anticipating that period of travel and
how you're going to work around it
will prevent your workout routine from
falling through the cracks but if you
scramble to find a a gym right when you
land in new york city you'll probably
not end up doing much at all unless you
have some external cues like your apple
watch is telling you to close your rings
on that particular day
so the second step is eliminating as
many
external distractions and interruptions
as you can but also internal
distractions and interruptions uh
keeping a distractions list if your mind
veers off to think about something that
you have to do as you as you focus on
something yeah it is one powerful
distractions list yeah it's so i i have
many pages
of distractions here uh it's just a list
of anything that you want to do that
isn't what you have intended to do
uh so i if you really want to
focus on something you know you set a
timer
for however long you want to focus on
something and your mind will
go all over the place you'll think about
somebody you need to email you'll think
is somebody you need to follow up with
you'll think of something you need to
buy on amazon you'll think of just all
you'll think of the fact that you need
to buy cantaloupe on your way home
tomorrow uh when those things arise you
put them on the distractions list so
that when your focus timer goes up and
the duration of which will get
increase over time as as you get better
at this skill of deliberateness
um
when when that timer goes off you can
tend to what's on your distractions list
so you don't veer off track what's the
difference between that and a capture
process from gtd nothing right okay cool
yeah nothing at all
people that are listening will probably
be familiar with getting things done uh
have you had david david's been on the
show
he's great he's absolutely fantastic he
was the one that introduced me to a
vertical bookcase so he's got oh in his
office
he's got a vertical bookcase um which
has a copy of getting things done in
each of the 73 languages 73 some in same
number of languages it's been translated
into wow uh and he had this bookcase and
i was really impressed by it and then i
ended up buying two of them so uh david
if you're listening thank you for the
suggestion and uh
send me a link after it's dude it's
absolutely dope it's the coolest thing
that where the phillips hue strip oh the
back of it a little bit away from a wall
and you've got what looks like a
vertical tower of books like a halo with
a halo around gorgeous it's good oh at
least i think it is i think it's cool um
right
it's funny because when i've chatted
with him i always thought it was just a
stack of books
at any moment first thing i said i was
like david that's a
big tall style
it's actually a vertical bookcase chris
um
okay so
that's us looking at
how we can bring a little bit more focus
in yeah
what about environment design because
having an environment which engenders a
particular type of mindset
is something that i think most people
will be familiar with
i think it's broadly understood that
you're supposed to go from
a place to a place to a place and if you
can try and have this is the place where
i do my
work this is the place where i watch my
netflix or a lot of the time people like
myself maybe even have different devices
that they do things on so i have i have
a type of device for social media i have
a type of device for watching netflix on
i have a type of device for doing emails
and so on um what did you learn that was
new or novel when it comes to focus and
environment design oh oh there's
there's there's so many directions to go
uh i'll i'll share just one because i
tend to ramble as yes you can tell by
now what 53 minutes into the podcast or
however long you edit this down to
53 minutes 53 mins baby let's go uh so
what one one interesting thing that
that i found in the research is
the extent to which how messy our
environment is uh influences uh how we
think
uh and so we're more creative
when our environment is messy
and we're more productive and focused
when our environment is clean
and the creativity is informed by
these different environmental
cues that send
ripples of of thought through our
unconscious mind that
when those ripples hit
an idea that becomes sufficiently
activated so as to break through
into our conscious attention lead us to
a creative insight right this is when
you're walking through a bookstore and
you're just kind of you know wandering
to think about ideas
and then
you encounter some random cue
that leads you to think about
a brilliant idea you wouldn't have
arrived at otherwise it's kind of like
scatter focus it's kind of a similar
mode uh dreaming is the same way there's
the
the the dreaming
brain network that we have is a neural
correlate with the daydreaming network
that we have is just intensified and we
have less awareness to when when this
mind when this mode is activated i'm
sure that you'll have heard the story
was it
isaac newton that used to fall asleep
with ball bearings in his hand i think
it was edison edison yeah used to go for
a nap in the middle of the afternoon
thinking about the maths problem or some
sort of issue that he was coming up with
ball bearings in his hand as he fell
asleep the ball bearings fell out of his
arm yeah hit the floor woke him up but
what he was doing was he was using that
sort of liminal
sleep state that perry sleep state to
get him into
that
default mode switch it off yeah
yeah and then he would go and write
stuff on the board yeah and what what a
beautiful way of harnessing the i don't
know if my schedule is conducive to
holding the handful of marbles over over
a metal plate
and waking up when they when they hit
the plate but
you know whatever you can do to activate
alcohol is kind of similar too
to sleeping because when we consume
alcohol our mind wanders more but we
become less aware of the fact that it
has wandered in the first place so when
you have a drink your mind is more
likely to wander off to some far far
away place and you kind of snap back to
reality oh there goes there goes your
attention again and uh
and
you know but you're less aware
you know our metacognitive skills
plummet when we consume alcohol so
journaling if you have a glass of wine
or or scotch
nearby can be a helpful reflective
strategy too
go back through what you said a little
bit earlier about the elements that
make it more likely that we're going to
put a task off because i think that that
um
structural identifier for a lot of
people will be
um they continue to come up against
things that throughout their week they
just
procrastination is like inbuilt into
them doing the task even if the task is
routineized so what are some of the
common ways that tasks can
be structured in a way that makes us
want to put them off and also give us
some solutions yeah for sure
so those are i'll try to recall them
this is a true test of
whatever i don't know this is a true
test of how good of an editor you are on
the pipe no i'll try to do it
so those are whether a task is boring
uh whether it is frustrating so the
process is tedious whether it's
difficult uh or ambiguous
um no those are so whether it's
difficult whether it lacks personal
meaning so we can't connect with it uh
whether it lacks intrinsic rewards
and whether it is ambiguous or
unstructured so the process of doing it
is not
rewarding in and of itself
and so you can look at something like
doing our taxes is a really good example
or you know you're a business owner but
bookkeeping is another good example of
this where that's boring that's
frustrating that's difficult there's no
meaning in paying taxes unless you i
don't know maybe you find meaning in
that uh it's ambiguous this is why the
half trillion dollar tax prep industry
exists in the united states um netflix
not boring not frustrating this is why
we
engage with netflix as we put off other
things because it's kind of the opposite
of this
but what we can do
with this knowledge is we can look at
something that we're putting off and we
can compare
how we relate to that task because it's
about us
right to two people can relate to a task
completely differently we all have
different interests we and we'll have to
adapt for that but we can look at what
triggers a task sets off
in order to
connect with why we're putting something
off and and so that's kind of the first
of all the the the awareness of why
we're putting something off in the first
place but it's like i think you
mentioned this a bit earlier defining
the very next thing you have to do to
move something forward
that's a simple strategy but it works
because it disables a few of those
triggers it makes something immediately
more structured it makes it immediately
less ambiguous
and a few of the other ones as well
shrinking how long we do something for
until we no longer feel resistance to it
this works really well for meditation
which is in itself a process of
understanding the resistance embedded
within the depths of our mind
we can shrink how long we meditate for
this is an idea that i that i found from
my friend john kropp who teaches
meditation to lawyers um
what he'll do is he'll guide people
through okay do you want to meditate for
half an hour no way in hell the thought
of it puts me off okay what about 20
minutes no what about 50 no 12 no 10
maybe i could i could do 10 and so you
meditate for 10
and in the process of understanding that
resistance and getting to a level that
is just beneath it
uh you know first of all the resistance
we have to doing things is stacked at
the very beginning of a task it's
jumping in a cold pool uh
you know once we do so we acclimate very
quickly but understanding that
resistance and working with it makes
something more structured less ambiguous
less frustrating and we see that there's
an end in sight
and so the process becomes a bit more
rewarding too
one other random idea that comes to mind
is connecting with our future selves
so our future self is
ourself
but
from the future it's just ourselves in
the future
and so when we put something off
we're giving it to ourselves to do our
future selves to do
uh and here's the interesting thing you
know speaking of the science of of
productivity a little bit
um if you were to wheel somebody into an
fmri brain scanning machine and you ask
them to think about
themselves in the future but also just a
total stranger like i don't know taylor
swift comes to mind because i've been
listening uh to her music all day as
i've been writing great simple music
what you would find
is
the two brain scans would be virtually
identical to one another
for most of us most of us view our
future selves as a stranger
and what this does and this is a measure
called our future self-continuity so
it's just a measure of how tight we are
with our future self
if you find that you continually put
things off to tomorrow when you give it
to your future self you need to
raise
your level of future self continuity so
that you don't feel as though the things
you're putting off are something you
give to a stranger like taylor swift do
so that you have this connection to this
this timeline of your life
and so a couple of ways of doing this
one of my favorite actually this is a
video podcast like i can get the picture
and you can edit out the dead air in the
audio look at the production quality
over here uh this is this is a picture
that it people think people when they
visit my uh
my office here they first of all they
think wow this guy's really full of
himself because he has a picture of
himself across
across the the way there but then they
see the picture and then they think i'm
just a weirdo uh this is a picture of me
created with an app called aging booth
and there's another one called face app
that does pretty much the same thing it
can show you what you're like in the
future uh they they have done studies
where they they put somebody
with a con control group obviously and
they put some they give somebody a live
projection of their face
but the the projection is aged
20 30 years into the future
and then at the end of this experiment
right after somebody sees this
projection of themselves answering just
some random questions
they gave the two groups of participants
a thousand dollars to
either
you know a theoretical thousand dollars
or else it would have been a very
expensive experiment
they gave everybody this grand to divide
between their present selves
and save for retirement and what they
found is that those who saw this
projection of their future self saved
significantly more for retirement
compared to those who didn't
and those who are more connected with
their future self they save more money
for retirement overall
they're less likely to put off work to
tomorrow less likely to agree to
unproductive meetings
so connecting with your future self you
can print you know you can
frame frame a picture of it if you want
but also just journaling about
alternative futures you know one in
which you make the change that you've
been putting off one in which you you
build that pipeline of
of podcast episodes and don't put that
off and another where you don't and
suffer the consequences
that leads you to step into the shoes of
your future self and by the way by the
way this is why the rule of three works
so well in that frame
at the you fast forward to the end of
the day and you think what three things
will i want to have accomplished
that's your future self same with every
week same with every year
it's it's in bridging the gap between
where we are and where we want to be
that we overcome procrastination that we
get to where we want and so yeah
understanding the triggers connecting
with our future self
creating a bit more structure by
defining the next thing or shrinking
resistance uh one final
way is to list the costs of putting
something off and so the fascinating
thing about procrastination is it is a
purely visceral
and emotional reaction to something that
we do not want to do
like there's no logic embedded within
the construct of procrastination
whatsoever
and so
when we list the costs of doing
something we activate the logical
centers in our mind to overcome
that emotional impulse
there's a procrastination researcher
named tim pitchell
who describes procrastination as when we
give in to feel good when we give into
that that emotional uh instinctual
part of us and by firing up that logical
prefrontal cortex in our mind we we
overcome
uh those impulses so long-ass answer i
know but that's a bit a bit of a geek
out on the
psychology of procrastination i think
it's important
a question i've been had i've had in my
mind for a little while
do you think
that people who think about productivity
are happier on average than the people
who don't
no
i don't
and i would agree in my experience it i
think it well i think it relates to
savoring
um people who
focus too much on accomplishment i think
accomplishment
uh focus drives productivity focus often
because they're
it's like you see productivity is in
service of the thing right
exactly it's like you said our micro
actions contribute to to our goals
overall
there there's actually been studies that
that are conducted in in this field of
uh savoring research
where they found that the wealthier
somebody is
the less likely they are to savor their
lives
and
savoring
is you know just when we enjoy something
in the moment
and it's the process through which we
convert
um
experiences
positive experiences into positive
emotions
right when you have this cup of of green
tea and you
enjoy every sip and you find yourself
present with every sip
that that creates meaning right when you
enjoy the the things in your life that
are good
but the research shows that the more
accomplishment driven somebody is the
less likely they are to enjoy their
lives the less time they spend savoring
savoring is a skill that we can get
better better at over time but i i
completely agree that the more driven
somebody is
the more ambitious
especially to achieve traditional
measures of success somebody is
the less happy they are yeah that seems
to be the case i think so
there seems to me to be a undercurrent
at the moment of
new wave
productivity
slash lifestyle design
writers coaches influencers that are
taking a much more holistic
broad
uh frame view yeah i think you would
fall into that i think that ali abdol's
new yeah uh book is is moving toward
that but you see everybody kind of
entered this world in the
gary vaynerchuk hustle and grind until
your eyes bleed like that kind of gtd
how many things can i get out of my day
i'm going to delegate i'm going to have
my system set up so and so forth right
how much can i automate and how much can
i just
brute force achieve yeah and then over
time you realize that if the goal of
productivity is to do the thing that you
intended to do and the thing that you
intended to do is to live a life which
in retrospect you're glad you lived yeah
all of the things that you take
on the step to do that are all
they're all not in service of the end
goal of actually being happy or living a
meaningful life yeah and i do think if i
was to be able to bet on a prediction
market for this i'd say that there's
probably a pretty high
likelihood that you're going to see a
movement toward this holistic high
performance
more fully rounded productivity
view that yeah
the satisfaction that you get from
getting things done and from moving
yourself towards your goals is important
yeah that is only correct when it's
mediated by moving yourself toward goals
that you genuinely want so working out
what you want working out what you want
to want working out how your
intentionality and your deliberateness
on a day-to-day basis ensures that the
things that you do move you toward it
then only after you've done all of that
to the actual tactics around
implementing something that facilitates
all of the layers that are above it only
does that then come in and then finally
you need to be able to have the off
switch as well
yeah so we've had this big big big bulk
of productivity work which has come out
over the last sort of 10 and 20 years
which is really easy to read cal
newport's deep work you know seminal
books like awesome really really great
books amazing books
and yet
there is this whole other side of
what's this in service of
what are you doing outside of this does
this contribute to your long-term goals
of happiness and meaning is it making
the world a better place all of this
stuff i think is
what's next and i'm hoping that
the question of our people who think
about productivity happier on average
will be flipped because what people
um what
exists under the umbrella of
productivity
in five to ten years time
should hopefully include people who have
worked out how to optimize their off
time who have worked out how to optimize
their intentionality their
deliberateness their micro actions
contributing to their long-term goals
their
scattered focus that you know all of
that stuff so i think that the more
holistic and the more wide-ranging it is
the better it'll get but i would agree
that at the moment we're not quite there
yeah and
i think what would define
this field as being holistic
is that the values that we
manifest through our actions and through
our pursuit of productivity
aren't just related to cold
accomplishment which doesn't really
prove to be a satisfying end in and of
itself
you know you can always accomplish more
there there's one study that
that i encountered that asked everybody
of all incomes how much
they more they wanted to make to be
happy and no matter how much somebody
made
they said 50 percent more than what they
already made
and that includes the wealthiest people
that were surveyed and i think that's
indicative of something
deeper which is that the problem is not
that
the problem is the pursuit of more
at all costs right and that's that's
pure
um you know it's it's all about what
values you're manifesting through that
pursuit of productivity i think if the
values you're manifesting are are greed
are
just attaining more of everything that
you have because your life revolves
around dopamine which is what propels
this
pursuit of more but also propels us
toward distraction right seeking more
of everything that we have including
more money as well as just checking
instagram more are directly related
because both are the result of a of a
mind that is overly dependent on
dopamine
i i really hope we see
going into the future i'm going to try
that to do this in my own work as well
i in fact just handed a book in last
week uh about
this more
holistic
holistic's the best word i can come up
with right now but this this warmer
uh this friendlier this this uh more
meaningful it's a more global view i
think of yeah of what people want out of
productivity dudes i mean you're in
you're in the position to do it you know
people like you and ali and kyle have
the opportunity to use the influence to
not only be able to get people to do
lots of things but to actually
understand what it's in service of yeah
and i i'm like i say if i could bet if i
could put some money down i'd put a good
bit of cash down that i think this is
the next big
the next big sort of push that we're
going to see you have this
um
sort of swing right like a pirate ship
yeah you have
intensities up to one side you have
intensities that come back to the other
and then you find somewhere in the
middle that is about the right level and
i think that hopefully we're going to
see
counter to some great productivity books
we're going to see some sort of
anti-productivity or what you do outside
of it yeah and then those two blended
together so yeah the next the next five
to ten years i think of writing in this
space is going to be really cool and
you're well positioned to do it man so
whatever it is that's coming out next
i'm excited to see it
i can't wait
uh chris bailey ladies and gentlemen if
people want to check out what you do
where should they go
so my books i i have saved the plug for
the end of the show uh hyperfocus is the
one that you've intense name but really
just about acting more intentionally
every day uh productivity project is
where uh the product is my other book
where i've pulled some of that
procrastination some of those
procrastination ideas from and time and
attention is the name of my podcast as
well uh my site is a life of
productivity.com i think that that's
enough plugs is that all of your blog
posts on on yeah and they're all up
there for free there's an annoying
newsletter pop-up that you need to x out
of but everything is ad free and you
know i put it out there for uh you know
because i i kind of my whole business
model is i share
whatever i can
freely in the hopes that people will
either buy the books or book me for a
speaking speaking gig because those are
the main revenue sources and then try to
give out as much as i possibly can for
free
outside of that dude i appreciate you
thank you for coming on thanks so much
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
you